what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our discussions on DC
rebirth we pick up now with Hal Jordan
and the Green Lantern Corps in fact what
we're gonna do when we get around to the
end of this video is we're gonna kind of
round out this discussion on DC rebirth
just because of the fact that the end of
this story will actually see and even
the story itself will see kind of a
return to familiarity with regards to
characters that we haven't seen for
quite some time and again sort of set
the stage for what DC rebirth really is
not really set the stage but kind of
explain what DC rebirth you know is is
really all about but initially we pick
up here with the Templar guardians now
the Templar Guardians are kind of
interesting because as far as I'm aware
they just vanished one day like they
vanished really when it came to the
character of relic in order to keep from
spoiling things too much because we'll
talk about the Templar guardians as we
go through our Green Lantern videos on
Sunday the Templar guardians are
basically a subset of the guardians of
the universe that are guarding an
exceedingly powerful being like a being
that's literally going to lay waste to
the entirety of all the Lantern course
it's good it's gonna be a bloodbath but
it's one of the best stories ever but
the other half of this is that the
Templar guardians as far as I'm aware
basically like vanished during the whole
thing with relic and what I mean by that
is eventually the Templar guardians
basically stepped away from their role
or really there was no need for them to
maintain their role anymore and they
kind of took up the position of the
other guardians of the universe and the
result is that instead of being removed
from the universal landscape which is to
say kind of keeping themselves hidden
off and really being obsessed with the
fact that they were right all the time
the Templar guardians wanted to have
more of a hand in things now this led
into the introduction of relic basically
a character who was from a previous
universe I think it was and it was the
idea that his universe had basically
been overrun and destroyed by people who
were harvesting and using the emotional
spectrum and he wanted to keep that from
happening in the DC universe as it
existed now and so whose goal was to
basically destroy all the lanterns but
the fact remains here it is pretty cool
because the Templar guardians after that
again as far as I'm aware they were just
gone all we got was just ganthet and
sayd in DC Comics and that's it it is
interesting and it's kind of intriguing
because it does really see them come
back here so it may very well be either
this you know this back end gets
explained assuming that you know I'm not
missing something but at this point we
actually transition over to a newly
introduced Green Lantern which is
actually a kid and it's cool because
when it comes to the Green Lantern's
more often than not when we see Green
Lantern's we see them usually as like
young adults or adults and so they've
kind of reached that point in their life
where they were like okay so like it's
time to get down to business before a
kid they respond exactly the way that we
would like if we were given a Green
Lantern regular we're just gonna fly
around and have like the most fun ever
and that's exactly what happens you know
this kid experiencing experiences all
the joy and that's the benefit of this
is that it's kind of a fresh and flux of
innocence into a Green Lantern quark
that's been through so much because
remember the green lanterns during the
whole you know lost army and edge of
oblivion story they were basically
pushed almost to the brink of extinction
I mean their numbers dwindled down to
what amounts to a handful relative to
how big their numbers used to be before
where they were in the thousands now
they're down to you know a few dozen
maybe a hundred and so the result is
that they're they're really doing the
best they can to kind of keep everything
intact what did he does here is he very
much writes this in a way where it's
like children of men for example you
know humanity's on the brink of
destruction and you know and no one's
having kids anymore and then suddenly a
woman gives birth to a kid and it's like
that iconic scene from that movie when
you know the rebels are fighting against
the British soldiers and then you know
this baby starts crying and the whole
conflict stops everyone stops until this
baby leaves and then the conflict kicks
back in again that's really what this is
designed to be it's innocence it's you
know Jon Stewart is the leader of the
Green Lantern's I almost forgot what
it's like to see a child enjoy life in
such a capacity because remember they're
out in space so they're largely removed
from all that stuff it is cool here
because this is one of those things
where ganthet kind of hinted the idea of
hey say do you ever thought about having
a kid but of course her or her response
is well I mean I assume you're talking
about like lowering the restriction I
assume you're not talking about having a
child because we're kind of old and I
don't know if I could survive it but the
fact remains here the cool thing about
vendetta's writing is that it's very
reminiscent of classic Green Lantern
stories in the sense that the whole
thing would kick up and then here's what
the Green Lantern's are doing while it's
going on now a lot of that's because of
the fact that when Geoff Johns took up
the green lantern line of comics it was
just one series of events after another
it's just event after event after event
after event Sinestro Corps war blackest
night brightest take all these things
just one event after another and so
there really wasn't a whole lot of time
to kind of show the downtime of lanterns
I mean there was to a degree but it
wasn't a huge focal point he was
building up the mythos and expanding all
these cores and all that kind of cool
stuff and so it's almost like vendee
Dee's run at least right now in DC
rebirth is more like us catching our
breath kind of sitting down and saying
okay now let's see what the Green
Lantern's are about and it's cool
because we get this moment you know
between Hal Jordan
and can't later you know where they're
talking about you know they're putting
things back together and they're helping
a civilization survive you know that the
eruption of the volcano and different
things like that problem with this is
that in the middle of ganthet and sayd
you know talking to this new green
lantern and you know basically informing
them over the role they play and the
importance of the power they possess
they're suddenly met by the arrival of
enemies that we don't see it so of
course GAD that tells us young girl run
you know go get Kilowog boot tell
somebody make people aware of what's
going on and then of course ganthet and
sayd are basically you know kidnapped
and taken away now from here this little
kid races off to the Green Lanterns and
it's like hey guys so like Anthony say
they've been kidnapped and things are
going crazy and we need your help and
it's kind of funny and so the result is
that what we end up finding out here is
that they've been taken by the
controllers now the controllers as they
exist in DC Comics really exists in a
couple different forms as you would
expect with characters who have been
around long enough there's the
pre-crisis version then there's the
post-crisis version the pre-crisis
version appeared back in like 1967 i
think it was and they were basically
characters who were just from like a
different universe and that was really
it I mean it was just one of these old
Jim shooter style stories from way back
in the day where it was like well I mean
you know they came from a different
universe and you know something like
that and they were trying to keep this
universe from being destroyed or someone
those lines the controllers as we know
them really it's their post-crisis
origin and the post-crisis origin for
the for the controller's themselves what
we end up finding out is that we're
originally you had the Malthusians who
basically evolved to become the
guardians of the universe what we ended
up having was that some of them actually
defected some of them went away and
basically the male's broke off and what
to do their own thing and they became
the controllers they kind of
hyperaccelerated their own evolution and
manipulated their own structures
different things like that leading up to
their current state now the females left
and they became the zamarons they became
the star sapphires but the result is
that those individuals who stayed became
the guardians of the universe and so
that's kind of how those two groups
progressed but it is cool because the
controllers were always kind of
hell-bent on doing exactly what they
sound like controlling things and so
largely the controllers were enemies of
the Guardians and the Green Lantern's
and that was really about it now of
course bigoted rulers also really made
there at least one of the big moments in
modern history when it came to really
the introduction of Larfleeze as the
orange lantern some of the controllers
had shown out trying to capture the
power of the orange lantern and they
were basically killed by Larfleeze and
that was really about it but again the
controllers as you've seen them and the
more recent stories of Green Lantern's
you know leading up to DC rebirth and
two new 52 you that's about the max that
you got I mean they're really
reminiscent of an older age of Green
Lantern comics that people don't really
read about anymore and so it is kind of
intriguing but the basis behind them
kidnapping the Guardians is that while
they are at their own sub-sect of a race
now they do all stem from the same thing
and so genetically they are pretty much
identical they all stem from the same
genetic pool and so the logic of the
controllers is to basically find a way
to essentially strip the guardians of
their genetic material to harvest them
more or less and then repopulate the
controllers because remember much like
the Guardians it doesn't really seem
like the controllers are able to
procreate using traditional means and
even if they could they're all dudes so
I don't really know how you'd be able to
pull that off but the fact remains here
it is kind of cool because in response
to this of course the young the the new
Green Lantern the little kid Green
Lantern is asked by Jon Stewart what do
they look like the people that took you
know the the guardians and the result is
that they end up just kind of showing
what their physical appearance was which
of course leads to the controller's
themselves so of course you know
following this you basically have this
kind of all hands on deck everybody
jumping in trying to figure out what's
going on so on and so forth and it does
make sense I mean it really kind of
works in the sense that all the
guardians are just kind of responding as
we would expect but with Jon Stewart and
Guy Gardner in Hal Jordan and Kyle
Rayner it is kind of personal for them
because ganthet and sayd really sort of
represent this idea that the guardians
of the universe themselves are taking a
more traditional role more of a hands-on
role in the universe as opposed to being
shut off from it not only that the fact
that Jon Stewart returned with all the
Green Lantern's and then ganthet and
sayd kind of backed off and allowed him
to continue running the Green Lantern
Corps on its own does allow for a
measure of trust between the two groups
because one of the things you guys will
notice over the course of our you know
Sunday Green Lantern run is that for the
most part a lot of distrust is being
sowed between the guardians of the
universe and the Green Lantern's and the
sense of the Green Lantern's are slowly
beginning to realize the guardians of
the universe house many secrets and they
don't really tell a lot of the Green
Lantern's what are going on if they even
tell them at all it's one of those
things well you will learn what you need
to know when you need to know it and
that may or may not count now the other
half of this is you know once we jump
back in and the end the Templar
Guardians or at least some of the
Templar Guardians are being harvested
this is a way for Venditti in them to
basically begin winding down the number
of guardians to basically say we're
gonna start decreasing than a number
slowly but steadily and it does make
sense you know in the sense that this is
kind of their overarching or at least
his overarching goal assuming that's the
case because remember ganthet and sayd
being the Odeon I'll only Guardians has
actually been a pretty popular theme in
the Green Lantern landscape for quite
some time just because of the fact that
the Guardians have always been a focal
point of a Green Lantern stories and in
a lot of ways it's one of those things
where all the stories that can be told
have been told and so if that's the case
then where do you go from there will you
simply change things up you switch
things around you move the pieces across
on the board and you switch players out
and you really just kind of try your
hand at making things starkly different
than they used to be and it actually
works now the other half of this is that
again I would surmise that with a lot of
these Templar Guardians basically being
eliminated you know essentially being
removed the other reason for why it was
that they effectively vanished was
because it allowed Robert Van diddy and
these guys really Sam Humphries as well
to begin introducing characters like
Randy to basically say well I mean
here's the new origin of the Green
Lantern rings and all those kinds of
things and it does make sense you know
in terms of that again because of the
fact of these Templar guardians are kind
of just being eliminated I don't really
see us getting a whole lot of exposition
in terms of what the Templar guardians
are about where they're from I imagine
DC just kind of relying and saying if
you know who they are cool if you don't
don't worry about it you know we just
kind of end up having to roll with the
punches now of course what the Green
Lantern's basically figuring out whether
controllers are operating from their
arrivals basically met with a handful of
mercenaries and again that's why I say
this is reminiscent of old-school Green
Lantern's storytelling because this is
what you would see and like the 60s 70s
and 80s man like some events taking
place with although good Green Lantern's
are gonna have to respond but then he
runs into an unexpected enemy can he
overcome them yes he can now on to the
main foe that's basically how those
stories were told because DC rebirth is
designed to wrap back around to the
old-school standard of comic book
storytelling more adventure more fun as
opposed to like super serious grounded
realistic tangible stories because at
the end of the day comic books are
designed to be an escape or at least a
lot of people view them as as an as an
escape and so that's really what this
becomes I mean for the love of God
you've got Jon Stewart a Green Lantern
creating a bazooka out of his ring and
firing rockets out of it I mean if that
doesn't scream spacefaring escapades and
zonkers storytelling I don't know what
does I have no idea what does now of
course the the Green Lantern's are able
to overcome these foes quite readily
about this remember it's kind of a
return to what makes the Green Lanterns
storytelling so well it's very much
forming this kind of camaraderie and
that was something that in a lot of ways
had kind of been missing from the Green
Lantern stories for a little while in a
lot of ways the characters kind of fell
rank-and-file but the idea of them kind
of coming together and saying okay so
like the four of us like the Four
Horsemen of the of the Green Lantern
landscape were the only ones who can
really pull this off it works and it's
really kind of a good feeling because it
brings you back to these old Green
Lantern stories back in the day now of
course the funny thing about this too is
the controllers weren't really betting
on the Green Lantern's I mean they they
kind of say they were but they were
really expecting this idea that the
Green Lantern's would just kind of wait
for a sign from the Guardians or
something along those lines of course
the Green Lantern's respond and
basically just kind of start ripping
things up but remember it's not designed
to be this thing where it's like the
Green Lantern's are here and the day is
saved everybody's gonna lose now it
takes this familiarity of old-school
storytelling and it blends it in with
the modern-day Green Lantern stories
that were used to and that in and of
itself is the quintessential definition
of DC rebirth grab the old-school style
of storytelling combine it with the
modern-day characters that you're used
to merge them together and then just see
what happens and it is cool because
ultimately when is enough having this
scenario where where jon stewart who
creates these a reflection disk and then
how Jordan fires off a beam which in
turn hits the machine hoarding the
gardens of the universe captive which
allows ganthet and sayd and the other
members to basically arise and step in
now again you will notice characters
like Ramy here we're not really given a
whole lot here just because of the fact
that remember the Hal Jordan and the
Green Lantern line of stories and the
Green Lantern's by Sam Humphreys those
are designed to be two distinctly
different lines of stories and so you
know Rama's basically been flushed out
of course we know he's the guy that
created the Phantom ring basically a
lantern ring that anybody can wield
attached into the entirety of the
emotional spectrum but it does kind of
fit in in the sense that if you're
following Green Lantern's
one feeds the other you follow Green
Lantern's and then you jump into how
Jordan in the Green Lantern Corps and
you know who Rama is you know who that
guy is
you know I'm figuring it out just like
everybody else is or you're reading Hal
Jordan in the Green Lantern Corps and
you're like who's that crazy looking
Guardian and then you go on you read
Green Lantern's rebirth and you're like
okay so that's like one of the older
Guardians says that's really cool now
ultimately of course with the defeat of
the controllers they end up making their
escape and it's kind of funny because
one of the Guardians actually wants to
kill him you know Zola wants to kill off
the controllers which is actually the
most illogical stance to take gaff it
really kind of being in a position where
he's like the new role that we play is
more of being guardians as opposed to
being like authoritative figures for the
universe we can't let this happen like
we can't just kill them they have to
stand trial assuming that we can catch
them again
and so that's the result because what
then did he does is he basically says
the controllers are back now the
controllers are gonna return to becoming
enemies of the Green Lantern's now again
this is just kind of grabbing on an
older enemy and rolling them in to DC
Comics and so following this what we end
up finding out in this epilogue of sorts
is that one the guardians of the
universe go back to their original
outfits which is to say basically that
red the white and the Green Lantern
uniform not only that the Templar
Guardians have kind of stepped out of
their role of just kind of exploring the
universe and are now back to being the
guardians of the universe and so it's
basically then did he sing okay so the
guardians of the universe are back
different people are playing roles who
were occupied by former guardians who
are now gone but they're gonna go back
to being the classic guardians of the
universe and it works again this is what
DC rebirth is it's a return to
familiarity ascribing all the old things
that you remember when you were a kid
when you were seven eight nine ten years
old and you are reading these comics
it's designed to grab those things and
bring them all back in and so it's cool
and and it really really works not only
that we end up finding out that the
controllers are basically bringing back
an older enemy again Michael I'm Michael
Jan Friedrich introduced these guys back
in 1992 they're bringing back the dark
stars the dark stars are cool the dark
stars are really really cool they are
basically kind of like this this merging
of the Manhunters and the Green
Lantern's kind of combined into one it
was really the attempt of the
controllers to create their own version
of the Green Lantern's or own police
force and then just sort of go forward
from there and so again this is gonna
see kind of a return to familiarity
these old things coming back and again
it's it works it's really solid and it's
really really interesting but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained and make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]